The idea of dream analysis, I suppose
Is one of Freud's - perhaps Freud's major contribution
To modern western thought
The idea was there was something - two dreams
And I suppose what Freud did was said "Hey look, isn't it strange?
We have this whole other form of thought that we engage in, at night,
and it speaks in a language that we don't really understand."
And so, what the hell is that?
And you can say, and many modern people do, dreams are of no significance
Or even that they're random processes, which is an absurd proposition - obviously
Because - whatever they are, they're obviously not random
So, Freud's idea was that there was something in dreams that was informative
So that's his - Now, he had a method for extracting out from the dream
What
The dream purported to represent
And he outlined that in great detail in the interpretation of dreams
And, if you want to read one book by Freud I would highly recommend that one
It's a very long book and it's very detailed, but
Freud does an extraordinarily complicated analysis of the way that dreams work
Now he - because he had brought a theoretical framework to bare
Even on his investigation into dream structure
he concluded that dreams were essentially wish fulfilments
And that's were Jung and Freud disagree
He also believed that the primary motivating factor of
human beings was sexual
Now that's a tougher one to toss aside because
even if you're a Darwinian, rather than a Freudian,
you're going to obviously support the proposition that
sexual motivation among any living creatures is going to be
one of the highest order of motivation,
Because, otherwise creatures don't reproduce and prevail
over the long run
So the question is that the ultimate source of motivation, in some sense is the
second time they lay out the dream and you can get a kind of picture of it
and then they lay out the dream a second time and as they go through it
The precursory of a thought in your imagination